i want to start by revisiting a question
which we looked at a couple weeks and we
debated do you remember
we're looking at whether maths was
discovered
or invented do you remember this yeah
good good good
um i just want to come back to this
question for two reasons number one
maybe you think we've answered this
question already haven't we arrived at a
conclusion to this
uh and if you think that it's a natural
thought but i think you've missed the
point
the reason why is because questions like
this right they're not like a
set of directions like you go from here
here and then you get your destination
and you're finished
questions like this they're more like um
they're more like lenses
they're like things that you look at the
world through and you examine different
things and you think okay now how can i
understand this
in terms of this and you look at
something else you look at something
else and then you see what happens right
so um the second reason why i wanted to
revisit this question
is because over the weekend um i went to
a conference uh it was a maths
conference so there's like i don't know
three or four hundred math teachers from
all over the state uh there's a lot of
nerds in one room it's a bit of a scary
sort of thought
but a couple of things that i did was i
went and attended these sessions that
looked at different kinds of maths and i
was thinking about that over the weekend
and they said some very interesting
things about this very idea and i'm like
did they know that our class was dealing
with this like they nailed it on the
head so two different ideas uh
firstly how to look at um how to look at
these kinds of things
so you can drop this down right now this
this is a cubic equation more
specifically it's a general cubic
equation
for any values of a b c and d okay
now cubic equations are very easy to
write and
they're not hard to understand like
we've looked at cubic equations before i
could give you something that would
expand out to a cubic equation
but cubic equations are actually very
difficult to understand the maths of
cubic equations
is super hard right um if i gave you
this
this is a linear equation and it's super
easy to solve the solution is
x equals 3 negative 3 right
no problem you don't even need to do any
working in the same way
something like this take a little more
mental effort
right but you can solve this quadratic
equations we have well established the
ways to work with these things
right and um so had ancient
mathematicians like the greeks and all
that kind of thing
they understood all this that was fine
but you just step up one more time step
one
step two and everything explodes people
were working on this
for centuries and what was really cool
is um this is
i don't know if they should go back to
this kind of idea but um
in the past particularly like in the
renaissance era if you were like a
teacher or a professor or something like
that
the way that you got a job was you
didn't apply and then have an interview
the way you got a job if supposed
suppose jack was the current
head teacher maths and i wanted to take
his job the way that i would do it
is i would challenge jack to a duel
right i i would write some questions
it'll be a math duel right
i'd write some questions that i know how
to solve and i'd give them to jack and
jack would do the same right
and we would see you know who would win
so it was kind of like
the more you know like that's how you
it's you fight it out and whoever can
answer more questions it's the winner
right
now these kinds of questions appeared in
these duels these kind of tournaments
these matches right
and it was kind of to your advantage a
bit like in a real fight
it's like if you know secret fighting
techniques right that the other guy
doesn't know
it's like i know this like weird nerve
pitch that i can do that will paralyze
you or something
then you keep it to yourself right you
find them out and then you're like i
don't keep this in my back pocket i can
whip it out when i need to
and i can you know fend off any
challenges right so the ways to solve
these kinds of things
they were viewed kind of like uh and
this is the word that the presenter used
when we were talking about this
they were kind of like discoveries that
you could make about different kinds of
versions of these you could solve and
how to solve them right
and it's a bit like like i said it's
like an arms race for who could solve
them faster
so when you look at it from this point
of view it's a it's a discovery thing
okay now there was another session i
went to and he was talking a lot about
lewis carroll you remember this
why were we looking at lewis carroll in
the last few weeks carol diagrams which
are an
alternative to venn diagrams you
remember that right so he didn't just
write alice in wonderland
he did a lot of maths okay and one of
the interesting things that i attended
uh that i got in this session was um he
said this sentence i wonder what you
think of this
in um stark contrast to this guy right
he talking about lewis carroll the math
that he did this presenter said
maths is purely invention
purely invention and the way he
justified it was this
i said to you maybe you want to write
down how to think about it later he said
think about the number three i don't
know why everyone picks three
three is an important number i guess
think about the number three
where does the number three exist where
is the number three
where can you point to and say look
there's that's three that's what three
is
now see this that's interesting right so
that's a symbol that came out of my
brain right like it's not a
it doesn't it's there because i wrote it
there right where is it in reality and
the answer is
well it exists in human minds
right like that's where it comes from
it's an idea
that we use and it's a symbol and all
that kind of thing but apart from that
it has no reality you take humans away
you take three away
right so that was his argument for why
was completely invented i thought that
was super interesting
okay so uh you can rule that off
now here's our this quote which refers
to something that we're going to cover
today which is on your handouts don't
quite turn it over yet
i'm going to read it to you just so you
can wrap your head around because it's a
very it's a very old quote
so the language is a bit hard right and
i want you to try and think as we go
through this
what do you think this is referring to
what's the they
that is the subject of this sentence
okay so it says
uh this guy this guy who's an english
mathematician francis m because i don't
know how to pronounce his saying
he said they whatever they are
they darken the very whole doctrines of
the equations
and make dark of the things which are in
their nature
excessively obvious and simple
so this guy francis versus this idea
what does he think of this idea does he
like it or does he dislike it
he dislikes it a whole lot right he's
like this is a terrible idea
whoever thought of this this concept
right it's just making everything
confusing we used to understand this
stuff it was obvious it was simple
and since some guy came along and
invented these it's just
confusing okay so i want you to think
about i wonder
i wonder what this is referring